[Music]
hello and welcome to I'd like to know
the smile on our faces indicates how
much we love this program amen and we
are so glad that you have joined us for
another session of I'd like to know one
of our favorite programs here my name is
CA Murray and I'm in the company of
Pastor Steven bore our president and
founder uh and good friend and Pastor
David Salazar uh the uh Guru of our
Latino Channel and who's doing a
fabulous job so we're here together and
we we have fun on this program for a
number of reasons one because we like to
study the word of God two listening to
the questions and reading the questions
gives us an idea of what's on your heart
and on your mind
and what issues you may be having and
what challenges you so we get a chance
to dialogue with you through the
television uh set and to understand what
is happening in your life and where you
are spiritually so it's fun because we
get to connect to you with you on on
that wise so it's a great program for us
and we pray it is a blessing to you
should you want to participate we hope
that you do we would ask you to write us
at TV atum tv.org
G that is TV at
tv.org and we will add your question to
this rather impressive pile of questions
that we have and we say that week after
week because sometimes people write and
they're a little upset because they
don't hear their question the first week
or so may we make you this promise we
will get to it we promise you but we
have a lot of questions and we want to
take due diligence and to due time with
each question don't want to rush through
you take the time to write us we want to
take the time to answer you as
thoroughly as we can and make you this
promise that if you do write we will
find an answer in the word of God if an
answer can indeed be found and we will
get it to you so have patience with us
please we're coming we will get your
question sooner or later uh Pastor bour
would you be pleased to pray for us and
then we're going to launch out we've got
some interesting questions today I would
be glad to let's pray Father in heaven
we come before your awesome throne and
we come boldly because we come in the
name of Jesus Amen we ask that as we
begin this program that your spirit will
hover over this place Enlighten our
minds that we might be able to answer
the questions in a way in which it's
understood and I ask Lord that you will
bless all of those who send in questions
that their hearts might be in tune with
you and they might get the answers that
will help their spiritual walk with you
amen and we thank you Father for hearing
our prayer for we ask it in Jesus name
amen amen amen and amen one of the
things that I noticed is happening with
much more frequency now is that people
are telling us where they are writing
from and that's exciting because we get
to know not only the footprint of the
ministry but where people are listening
to uh to us from and how they're being
blessed so this question comes from
Ghana uh the name is a little tough to
pronounce I would AG g b v
uh thank you for writing us um the
question is drawn from Romans 8: 26 so
if you have a bob you might want to turn
to that particular
text he quotes it here likewise the
spirit also helpeth our infirmities for
we know not what to pray for as we ought
but the spirit itself maketh
intercession for us with groanings that
cannot be uttered please help me
understand this verse by the will of God
most high
one
um does the verse concern tongue
speaking without the individual
himself without the individual
himself understanding what he says
because in Africa in Ghana uh to be
precise most charismatic and P
Pentecostal pastors are using this verse
to justify the Misunderstood tongue
speaking glad he put the word
misunderstood in there uh the reason is
that what the spirit of God Says with
groanings cannot be uttered or
understood and this results in such
tongues and two what is the meaning of
the statement cannot be uttered in the
in this context of the verse and this is
coming to us from
Ghana well unless you want to weigh
in you weigh in and then we'll weigh in
after you um
one of the things that um I want to
highlight because so much of what we
understand from trumps comes to us from
the the book of
Corinthians when you're dealing with
with Paul's counsel to the Corinthian
Church you're dealing with counsel that
is given to a church that is in trouble
it's in turmoil right so a lot of the
things that look like their
accommodations are not they are really
trying to correct issues that in the
church in turmoil so when you're drawing
examples for the Christian Church from
Corinthians uh to backup Romans you got
to be very careful how you make that
application because everything is not as
it appears to
be the other thing I would add before I
release it to you worthy Brethren is
that the spirit is doing the groaning
not you the spirit is is is speaking in
a language
not you so it is it is a mistake to say
that we are commanded to speak in an
Unown tongue this is a job of the spirit
which he does effectively you don't have
to do that so it's a it's a
misapplication of the scripture to say
that we are called to speak in tongues
no spirit's doing that as part of his
intercessory work right good point uh I
have a quotation here uh from the spirit
of Prophecy that might be help helpful
for
us um looks like I'm not going to be
able to bring it up there we go um where
Ellen White explains a little bit about
uh what the meaning of this verse is uh
this is Christ object lessons page
147 we must not only pray in Christ's
name but by the inspiration of the holy
spirit amen this explains what is meant
when it is said that the spirit maketh
intercession for us
with groanings which cannot be uttered
such prayer God Delights to answer when
with earnestness and intensity we
breathe a prayer in the Name of Christ
there is in that very intensity a pledge
from God that he is about to answer our
prayer exceedingly abundantly above all
that we ask or think Ephesians
3:20 many times we're pretty stingy when
we pray amen and then the holy spirit
says come on you got to ask more than
that uh and and many times we ask things
that are
selfish and the Holy Spirit has to wake
us up and say hey that's not what's best
for you so the Holy Spirit basically
what he does if I can use the word he
cleanses yes our prayers and uh he makes
sure that what we ask for is what's best
for us
right so I think that's included uh in
the answer there is no mention of
tongues in this verse right they're
inserting the word tongues there and we
we know from other passages that speak
about the gift of tongues that the gift
of tongues is the ability to speak known
languages that are unknown to the person
who is speaking them we know that from
the book of Acts we know that from other
places in in Corinthians as well uh so
there's no justification for inserting
here that we have to pray uh in an
unknown tongue because as C mentioned
it's the Holy Spirit who is uttering
these things it's not us it's not us
well said amen I also you know is
important to note that that verse verse
26 in Romans it starts with the word
likewise so it's connecting it to the
overall picture of the context and
sometimes the error of some people is to
take a verse out of the whole context or
what the context of the verse is is
really talking about to try to say what
they wanted to say instead of what the
Bible is TR trying to say and as Pastor
bour mentioned and we read in col in of
Leons page 147 it's the need for us to
pray also for the Holy Spirit to to help
us and supplicate in our have to to the
Lord uh for our intercession and is and
and the help of the Lord is is is kind
of describing here that he is through
the Holy Spirit trying to work in our
behalf and there is these groanings
which kind of the other is the the the
way that the spirit of God speaks in our
behalf to you know for to PR our prayers
for the Lord and uh making them of much
more of uh of much more power more
intercession for our benefit so I I
think that it's it's important that when
we look at these verses we look into the
context and we realize that it's
speaking of the need of men to be
restored to have that Victory to have
that salvation and Redemption and and
and this is what the Lord is working God
the Father God the son Holy Spirit are
working in our behalf in in the Plan of
Redemption amen you know it says that we
we we don't always pray for we know not
how to pray for what we ought you know
we pray see seeing half the picture yeah
we we pray things that we want we pray
things that we think we need we pray
things that we think would be best for
us or for our friends but God sees the
holy the whole picture holy spirit sees
the whole picture so some of those
things the Lord's got to tidy up you
said cleanse I I have dra the word
sanitize you know same thing same thing
I have a friend quick start I have a
friend Jeff Rodriguez he uh was the head
Deacon of the Newberg 70 Adventist
Church in Newberg New York prayed for
years for motorcycle his wife for said
no no motorcycle and after years and
years of praying she said okay you can
have the motorcycle so he prayed one
month he had that motorcycle bringing
his church on Sunday morning for
deacon's meeting hit a manhole cover and
boom he's he's out so now every time he
goes through the airport he he trips off
the the the U you know the thing that
you go through the metal detector
because he has metal in his hip from
that for from that wow you know he
prayed he wanted a motorcycle well he
got a motorcycle now he's got metal in
his hip for the rest of life we don't we
don't always pray for what we are right
sometimes you keep on praying Lord says
okay I'm going to let you have it but
you're going to have trouble you're
going to have trouble but the the Holy
Spirit dresses up some of our prayers
and makes them acceptable to the Lord
God's ways are not our ways God's
thoughts are not our thoughts yes he he
is omniscient he knows what we really
need right and not necessarily just what
we want what we want amen well said well
said thank you uh from Ghana we
appreciate that um this one comes from
Western Australia we are reaching out
praise the Lord this is Karen from
Western Australia I have a question that
bothers me for quite some time and I
would appreciate if you could assist me
finding the answer in the Bible my
question is are women not supposed to
not attend church on Sabbath when she is
unclean that is menstrual Purity and
excuse me she's drawing from Leviticus
15 mhm: 19
through 33 uh that talk about
uncleanliness of men and women and verse
31 says uh thus you shall separate the
children of Israel uh from their
uncleanliness lest they die in their
uncleanliness and they defile my
Tabernacle that is among
them so she's done a little research and
she couldn't find anything directly from
the spirit of Prophecy and so she's
asking us to weigh in on on this
matter well you know there's different
different kinds of
laws uh in the pentat the five books of
Moses uh you have the moral law and the
statutes which are an amplification of
the moral law you have ceremonial laws
which pointed in some way to what Christ
was going to do in the future uh you
have civil laws which govern them and
not other nations as such and you have
health laws right uh so uh
this prescription here is part of the
ceremonial law uh the laws of clean
cleanliness and
uncleanness uh refer to in some way to
the ministry of Christ and so uh what
applied back then does not necessarily
apply
now now she had a uh interesting concept
that I think is or her question also
mentions that she says that she
struggles to go to church when she's
during her menstrual cycle or she when
she's unclean and I think that you know
if if a a woman is is having uh
difficulty you know a lot of pain a lot
of uh situations that prevent her from
going to church I don't think that is
wrong for her to stay at home I mean and
and even though the Leviticus 15 um
verse 19 which speaks about when a woman
is with her period uh that she should
not you know touch what it's it's
definitely a I think a connection to to
a health law with a ceremonial
connection to it because of her
condition so you cannot use those verses
to apply necessarily to to a rule today
you know those are definitely more of a
ceremonial connotation as you mentioned
Pastor bore but the fact is that if she
physically is not feeling well there's
nothing wrong for her to stay at home
you know and and worship and and and you
know uh from her house so I think it's
important that she doesn't uh feel like
going to church defiles the temple no
longer that's applicable but if her
health it's you know you know she's in
pain and struggles it's okay to stay at
home as well you know during that time
she she ended that little statement with
I feel I struggle when I am unclean yeah
it she's not ceremonially unclean right
you know she may be having other issues
but but she shouldn't think that she's
rejected by God because of Any
ceremonial reason right um I have a a a
good friend my ey doctor for 25 years
was a son of a rabbi and while he had me
in the chair and we used to kick around
a lot of stuff you know kind of thing
and one of the things that we we talked
about was was was
uncleanliness um one of the things that
he suggested to me was that God was
trying to draw a line between a lot of
the sexual and fertility things that
were going on in Pagan religions and
that he was he was trying to let his
people know that that you know you had
Temple prostitutes male and female and
those kinds of things so he was saying
that when uh uh God's people are doing
things uh sexually or physically that
that that uh deal with the issuance of
semen or blood not only is this not fit
for the temple it's it's it's unclean it
makes you unfit for the temple so he was
drawing a line between Christian worship
or uh Hebrew worship and and Pagan
worship and this was one of the ways
that he was doing it but I think you you
both of your answers are quite well and
quite and quite and we also need to
understand that
hygiene back then was not the same as
hygiene now very true very because you
know particularly these laws as they're
going across the Wilderness right I mean
you know uh they the women did not have
protective measures right to use a
politically correct term going through
the desert or going to uh Services uh at
that time mhm right these days it's
different the hygiene is different
absolutely and is important you know to
emphasize as you both have mentioned
that this is more of a ceremonial issue
uh just like circumcision you know
circumcised could not enter into the
Tabernacle if somebody was not
circumcised so it's the same way in this
lesson you know the uncleanliness meant
mainly for the ceremonial aspect but uh
there is a health aspect to it that
could be applied today if needed but
just in the sense of of healthwise not
like you mentioned be cleaner and clean
before the Lord yeah you're dealing with
whoever you talk to three to five
million people if you had a problem you
couldn't just run to the shower right so
you had to take put in measures when you
got that many people together good
question and hopefully we um we we
answered it uh to her liking and to her
uh to her benefit uh we've got Debbie
from Washington State hello Washington
State who were the sons of God this
question comes up kind of like in job
1:6 uh given the context I believe that
the rulers of other
worlds that I believe them to be rulers
of other worlds but how do we know this
biblically she recites or cites rather
great controversy page
518 when when uh Ellen White wrote
angels of God and in this context she
she struggled with this a little bit so
can we help her out well I think Pastor
B has a a whole sermon on this
well I did a study several years ago of
the 24
Elders uh that are mentioned in the Book
of Revelation right and um I found some
statements from Ellen White where she
indicates that God has plac the highest
of angels to represent the worlds that
never sinned uh she she refers
specifically to the highest of angels uh
the other planet do not have
procreation like we do yes uh that's why
Jesus says that we're going to be like
the angels that do not marry or are
given in marriage and uh be because the
purpose for the creation of this world
was to replace the vacancies that were
left in heaven yes Ellen White has many
statements to that effect and uh so um
it wouldn't be a contradiction for Ellen
White to say on page 518 of great Conor
y that the Angels Came to present
themselves before the Lord in the Book
of Job right the fact is that if they
came to present themselves be before the
Lord they were not in the presence of
the Lord before MH and then you know
they must have gone back to where they
came from because in Chapter 2 it says
again they came to where the Lord was
which means that after the first meeting
they must have left uh so I believe that
the best explanation
is uh it reconciles both sons of God are
the highest of angels that represent the
worlds because each world has its
representative correct uh we know that
the representative of this world was
Adam MH and when he gave into the
Satan's Temptation Satan says well he's
my subject now because he gave into me
so now I'm the representative of this
world and Satan who was an angel one of
the highest Angels MH he um came to the
meeting representing planet Earth yes so
you know and some people get hung up and
this isn't uh in the question Itself by
the fact that uh in Genesis 6 it says
that the sons of God came uh they they
had sexual relations with the daughters
of men so they say well the Angels had
sexual relations with human beings but
we need to understand that an expression
needs to be taken within its context
correct correct uh sons of God the Bible
also says that we are sons of God you
know does that mean that we're angels of
course not or representatives of the
worlds no it's simply that the
expression sons of God is used in
different senses in Genesis chapter 6
it's referring to the righteous it's
referring to the descendants of Seth
right the immediately preceding context
makes that clear and the daughters of
men are the women that are mentioned in
the genealogy of Cain right uh so we
always need to take an expression within
the context in which it appears you know
a lion in the Bible can represent
Nebuchadnezzar it can represent Babylon
it can represent Christ it can represent
Satan and can represent Judah I mean all
different kinds take into account the
context yes a term or a phrase does not
always mean the same thing in every
context amen well said well said very
well said um when Satan came
representing the Earth uh the Lord said
you know what are you doing here U I'm
it's my Planet then that the reason for
the contest well have you considered my
servant Joe right you know maybe you
don't represent the planet so well said
uh well said there is a list in desar
Ages page 834 I won't go to it now but
she also makes that list of angels and
sons of God so uh you might want to add
that to your your collection of of uh
spirit of Prophecy quotes desire Ages
page
834 and uh well said I think we it's
interesting that they in in
834 it says that the representative of
the worlds came to the reception for
Christ when he ascended to heaven right
so the other end yes Ellen White has
many places where she talks about a
Heavenly counsel God is not a dictator
yes God doesn't say this is the way it's
going to be done that's the way it's
going to be done he could do that but
God has a Heavenly council with
representative he has kind of a
representative style of government yeah
you know where the whole universe is
represented and uh everyone has voice
and everybody can make their suggestions
yes you know there's there's a story of
uh of Mah who was brought from from
prison you know Ahab had cast him into
prison uh there was a meeting that took
place in heaven all the Heavenly hosts
were there and there was a Del
deliberation who's going to tell Ahab to
go to battle so he gets killed and one
said one thing and another said another
thing and finally Satan who is was able
to come at that time to the Heavenly
Council I'll do it and the Lord says how
oh I'll I'll be a lion spirit in the
mouth of His prophets so so there you
have representing planet Earth and you
also have the representatives of the
worlds that are deliberating about what
to do in this case that is taking place
on Earth
amen well said well said I think we have
dealt with that question very well um I
don't know we're down to one minute and
something second maybe we can get this
in really fast because this is from
Danny from he doesn't give us a a a
location
um his question is he he he's taking p
pills um that have Bine gelatin they
Bine gelatin capsules um he he needs to
take these supplements it's very
important for him um there are some that
upset his stomach
um he's he's asking if eating pork is a
sin if he has to take capsules that are
made out of pork but evidently the the
capsules he are taking are
Bine and is that a sin also well if it's
Vine meaning it's from house uh oxen or
buffalos which are clean animals
therefore they're not Pig if he's Vine
capsules I think he's fine yeah you know
it's not a sin yeah besides it's super
processed so it's not like eating the
flesh the the Flesh of the animal right
yeah you can go to Leviticus 11 split
horse split hoof rather choose the cud
it's fine uh well our time is fast lift
into eternity again we're at the end of
another program may the Lord bless you
we'll see you again soon bye-bye and God
bless
[Music]